[Musique]
je suis archi draps temps-ci bienvenue
dans going under ground émission qui va
sans doute avoir encore plus de
spectateurs après notre interview du
conseiller de la maison blanche pour le
coronavirus le professeur scott atlas
les critiques des médias traditionnels
et les excuses d'atlas pour nous avoir
accordé cette interview non pas empêcher
quelqu'un de nous rejoindre en plateau
alors que les électeurs ont voté pour
leur président l'avocat personnel de
donald trump et ancien maire de new york
rudy giuliani me rejoint par skype roddy
bienvenue dans going down c'est notre
émission spéciale consacrée à l'élection
pourquoi selon vous les élections
d'aujourd'hui sont elles les plus
importantes de votre vie j'estime qu'il
ya une nette différence entre les
directions que les deux candidats feront
prendre à notre pays
donald trump le mènera vers une liberté
d'entreprise et une croissance continue
de notre économie qui à la veille de la
pandémie a atteint un niveau sans
précédent
plus élevé que sous la présidence de
tous ses prédécesseurs il y avait plus
d'emplois à une augmentation des revenus
et une croissance économique plus élevée
et puis soudain on a été frappé par
cette pandémie tous les démocrates
disait qu'il fallait s'attendre à deux
ans de récession économique et à un taux
de chômage de 25% que nous n'allions
jamais en sortir ou que cela prendrait
des années
et voilà trois ou quatre mois plus tard
on voit un taux record de créations
d'emplois au cours des trois derniers
mois chaque mois est un mois record de
créations d'emplois la croissance du pib
ces derniers mois a été phénoménal de 33
3% ce qui est trois fois plus élevée que
notre record par le passé le résultat
final est qu'on a déjà rétabli
d'économie à 75%
nous l'avons rétabli davantage que tous
nos alliés notre économie est bien plus
forte que celle de tous nos alliés je
propose d'examiner même si nous avons
fait face à la plus forte récession il y
a une chose remarquable concernant
donald trump
on ne peut pas contester sa maîtrise de
l'économie de ce domaine un peu de gens
le conteste by john n'a jamais plongé
dans les problèmes économiques et
des idées infantile par exemple que
l'augmentation des impôts contribuera à
la croissance économique
ce qui est ridicule nous examinerons ça
un peu plus tard
mais avant même que le coc vide
n'anéantisse les progrès économiques que
l'administration trump dit avoir réalisé
il me faut demander cela aux sujets de
l'ombre de la russie alors même que des
enquêtes ont démontré qu'il n'était pas
un agent russe comment se fait-il que
ses collègues et vous même et y était
incapable de faire passer ce message et
mais brune bras seulement au royaume uni
mais aussi dans les états qu'il va sans
doute perdre cette nuit deux en un ied
d'abord il va gagner il va obtenir une
victoire surprenante
une des raisons pour lesquelles ce
message n'est pas passé c'est que 80%
des médias sont de manière totalement
maniaque en titre up au point que cela
confine à la pathologie
regardez la censure qui a été imposé sur
le disque dur et les milliers d'e mails
et sms de hunter biden il y en a un
autre qui a été trouvé à boston il est
entre les mains du fbi
ces disques durs contiennent
d'importantes informations relatifs à
des pots de vin de l'espionnage du
blanchiment d'argent
à partir de ces disques on voit que joe
biden a accepté des pots-de-vin son fils
le reconnaît il le décrit il ya une
censure totale de la part des grandes
chaînes des réseaux de la part des
grandes entreprises qui font des
affaires avec la chine
il ya une vraie frousse de français les
chinois et pour la première fois dans
notre histoire nous avons cette censure
opérée par le camp démocrate
c'est quasiment comme si les médias
était devenu pour les démocrates
ce que la pravda était pour le parti
communiste soviétique
c'est une arme du parti démocrate
il ne publie rien de bien au sujet de
trump ils ne publient
de mal au sujet des démocrates même si
on parle de mise en danger de mineurs de
pédopornographie d'espionnage de
corruption ok bien je dois dire
concernant ces allégations que joe biden
a dit monfils comme beaucoup chez nous a
eu des problèmes avec la drogue
il s'en est remis je suis fier de lui
cette absurde c'est absurde jeu du rire
quant à rudy giuliani du point de vue
des médias
c'est absurde laissez-moi répondre sur
ce point seul son fils n'en a pas fini
avec la drogue
j'ai des photos qu'ils prouvent cela
fait 30 ans que son fils a un problème
de drogue
c'est énorme et la seule raison pour
laquelle il a des problèmes de drogue
c'est joe biden c'était un jeune homme
avec un sérieux problème d'addiction au
lieu de les laisser simplement vivre une
vie normale
il a commencé à l'utiliser comme
collecteur de pots-de-vin pour lui donc
vous ne sortez pas un toxicomane de la
drogue en le faisant avoir affaire à des
meurtres et des criminels organisés
son fils est mouillé dans des affaires
avec un des plus grands escrocs
d'ukraine sogin membres du crime
organisé en ukraine
il a perçu 4 millions de dollars de la
part des l'ena batourina qui est une
bonne amie de vladimir poutine et à
aider à s'occuper de son mari
pour arriver à cette très importante
position j il a été associé à zilling
reconnu comme étant quelqu'un qui
entraîne des agents de renseignement et
place les gens dans des sociétés
fantômes à des fins d'espionnage ce
week-end chat et son associé patrick o
est décrit avec fierté par hunter by
donne comme son associé en affaires
alors qu'il s'agit d'un importante
espions chinois
il y a deux transactions chinoises
majeures l'une est un arrangement de 1,5
milliard de dollars pour le fonds de
private equity de hunter by donne au
moment même où joe biden négocié avec la
chine sur les taxes et la militarisation
deal
spitz et avec le japon dubai donne père
dans ces négociations et obtient
linverse mais d'un autre côté on te re
buy donne reçoit une lettre
huit jours après leur retour de chine
affirmant que cette dernière va mettre
plus d'un milliard dans son grotesque
fonds de private equity qui n'a jamais
généré d'argent et ensuite il devient
associé le fils du vice-président le
fils du secrétaire d'état john kerry le
fils de walter rogers qui est un
criminel notoire et la banque de chine
beaucoup de ces gens là disent n'avoir
rien fait de mal l'équipe de campagne de
joe biden dit qu'ils n'ont fait que
mener la politique officielle des
etats-unis envers l'ukraine n' ont rien
fait de mal que les documents fiscaux et
financiers de joe biden ne montre aucun
signe de transactions de hunter byden
vladimir poutine ni toute accusation
visant la russie est ce que le problème
n'est pas laisser moi vous répondre sur
ce point la dîmière poutine ne faisait
pas partie de l'accusation visant la
russie dont kilani ou qui la confirme
ça ne ferait aucune différence c'était
elena batourina
et c'est documenté et si quelqu'un avait
l'énergie de regarder ses disques durs
et non de les censurer comme le font les
médias américains
ils verraient que cela est prouvé il n'y
a rien à dire à ce sujet
quant à ses déclarations fiscales les
criminels ne mettent pas leurs pots de
vin sur leurs déclarations fiscales
j'ai poursuivi vingt cas de corruption
et une centaine de crimes
je n'ai jamais vu de criminels mettre un
pot de vin sur sa déclaration de revenus
jo est idiot mais pas à ce point cet
argent là se trouvent dans des comptes
offshore
les ukrainiens aimerait mettre les mains
dessus mais le trésor américain le bloc
depuis cinq ans ok ok mais est-ce qu'il
n'est pas possible
oui je suis demandé mais le fait est
qu'on peut voir l'argent arrivé sur le
compte
cet argent n'est pas pour hunter bailon
40e rebuy donne
sous crack tous les jours vous
n'imaginez pas combien de photos il y a
de lui so craque sur ses disques des
centaines et des centaines de photos
réfute ces allégations
mais ne pensez vous pas hunter by donne
n'est pas candidat à l'élection
on me suffit de regarder dans le disque
dur il nie mais il suffit de regarder
mais pensez vous qu'il soit possible
puis je finir ce que je suis en train de
dire bien sûr allez-y ce que je dis
c'est que vous voulez trouver la réponse
ne me demandez pas à moi allez voir dans
le disque dur
je veux dire je pourrais vous montrer
des images maintenant si vous souhaitez
les voir et je ne suis pas sûr que nous
avocats le permettrais je vais vous
montrer des images hockey
cette photo vient de son disque dur
vous avez vu ça vous ne pensez pas qu'il
a pu être mêlé à ses affaires sans que
son père ne le sache et soir à vannes
auray à flot après tout on parle de joe
biden et donc de son fils
j'ai bien passons à dubaï donne un
instant bloquer et lison lisons l'e-mail
du 3 janvier 2019
régis winter by donne dit à sa fille
faut que pendant trente ans il a
collecté de l'argent pour la famille il
faut qu'il paie pour les dépenses de la
famille ensuite il faut qu'il en donne
la moitié à son père donc ça concerne
joe biden qui utilise son fils de
manière ignoble comme collecteur spa ou
peut-être hunter exagérer les choses ou
parler de choses que son père ne savait
pas mais je voudrais aborder la question
de la censure dans ce cas pourquoi le
fils lui avait expliqué à son père ce
qu'ils faisaient une amie sont à des sms
dans lequel il s'occupe de bury ce mardi
on a désormais un témoin monsieur bobo
lansky qui est un ancien de la marine
qui a quitté cette dernière de manière
honorable
on virait pour prise de drogue qui dit
il y avait des discussions fréquentes
entre hunter et son père
concernant l'argent qu'ils faisaient en
chine avec les communistes chinois
on peut aussi considérer qu'on s'en
fiche mais le problème est qu'il n'ya
jamais assez de preuves
khoury l'appât du gain a remplacé le
patriotisme et la haine a remplacé ce
qui était bon pour le pays
il n'y a aucun doute là dessus mais
c'est bien le coeur de cette élection et
les américains le comprennent sur les
trois dernières semaines les sondages se
sont tout à fait inverser
souvenez vous que la dernière fois que
le président trump a gagné il avait un
retard de huit points et il a gagné
il faut voir l' enthousiasme au meeting
de trope et de bayonne il est difficile
à baden d'attirer 100 personnes schrunk
a attiré 35 mille personnes dans un
champ en pennsylvanie et 25000 personnes
sous la neige dans le michigan
les américains savent à quel point leurs
médias sont biaisés je voudrais vous
poser cette question quant aux médias
las le conseiller de la maison blanche
sur le corps d'un virus a vu un de ses
tweets supplie mais vous avez envoyé du
contenu au new york post twitter l'a
aussi fait disparaître à un moment donné
ils ont fait disparaître le new york
post pas noir ils ont fait disparaître
tous le new york post freinera filmé
trump avait trois ans et demi pour
réformer les médias il pouvait réformer
les médias aux états unis sans même
parler des entreprises technologiques
pourquoi ne l'at il pas fait mais parce
qu'il y a le premier abord il aurait
fait ça il aura été traîné devant les
tribunaux dans n importe quel libéral
serait devenu fou
vous êtes totalement irréalistes ou quoi
qu'est-ce que trump est obligé de tout
faire mal
la réalité c'est qu'un président
américain ne peut pas tomber sur les
médias comme ça allégorie giuliani je
vous arrête là on revient avec l'avocat
du président américain après cette pause
[Musique]
de retour avec l'avocat personnel de
donald trump rudy giuliani trump a
menacé twitter de non plus le considérer
comme un réseau social mais comme un
média et vous c'est ce qu'il voudrait
faire sauf que le congrès à majorité
démocrate ne leur ai jamais validé selon
vous combien d'argent uqar berg et
twitter verse au parti démocrate
des centaines de millions de fonds a
fondé le parti démocrate leur appartient
voilà pourquoi ils font ça il n'opère
aucune censure qui soit favorable à
trump leur censure est tourné contre
trump pour faire élire le candidat
qu'ils contrôlent joe biden si biden est
élu nous serons soumis à cette censure
pendant les quatre prochaines années car
ils sont de mèche
la raison pour laquelle ils méprisent
trompe et qu'il leur dit simplement
d'aller se faire voir et jeune actrice
n'a que leur est il ne les laissera pas
diriger ce pays et israël il a perdu
certains donateurs pour cette raison ici
j'ai ils sont venus le voir en disant
pourquoi n'y allez vous pas plus
doucement avec les géants de la tech et
il les a mis à la porte de son bureau
mais la réalité c'est que pour les
grandes entreprises technologiques et
les grands médias il s'agit du premier
président qu'ils ne peuvent malmené cas
exactement comme il le dit ces géants de
la technologie et des médias sont
l'ennemi du peuple boude quand on prive
les américains d' informations
essentielles sur l'élection
présidentielle on n'est pas à vrai
journaliste on n'est qu'un mercenaire de
la politique
voilà ce que twitter répond notre
politique est celle des contenus
évolutif nous voulons être en mesure de
les actualiser de les ajuster quand on
fait face à de nouveaux scénarios ou en
fonction des retours importants de la
part du public a vraiment pourquoi tout
ce qu'ils censurent sont des
conservateurs et qu il y a environ un
mois des déclarations de revenus ont été
publiés prétendument pour celle de
donald trump pour obtenir ça il aurait
fallu le volet il n'y a absolument
lui ment aucune authentification pour
confirmer qu'il s'agissait de ses
déclarations de revenus pas une page
signé il n'y avait même pas de sources
anonymes et ils ont publié ça et quant à
ce fameux email il y a trois sources
enregistrés cela peut être vérifié en
interne il s'avère que le fbi a fait des
recherches et c'est tout à fait vrai
pourquoi ces informations sont-elles
supprimés tandis que ces déclarations de
revenus sont publiés entre eux n'ont pas
été élus dans son discours d'investiture
qui je crois a été écrit par steve hanon
il a parlé de la classe ouvrière
américaine du carnage américain ce sont
ces raisons structurelles qu'on juge
souvent décisif dans sa victoire à la
présidentielle aux états unis selon vous
est-ce qu'il a viré à tort des gens
comme steve bananes et d'autres qui
étaient proches de lui en 2016 qui ont
mené sa campagne sur ces questions
sensibles des états industriels délaissé
je veux dire il a abrogé l'accord de
libre échange nord américain il a fait
ce que c'est et a désiré at il besoin de
plus d aides avait-il besoin de plus de
soutien
il a obtenu des résultats remarquables
steve est un ami proche et il soutient
vraiment le président le fait qu'il y a
eu des remaniements au sein de
l'administration est tout à fait normal
je ne vois pas ce qu'il aurait pu faire
de plus pour améliorer ses résultats
grâce à lui notre économie a atteint son
meilleur niveau au même point il ya plus
d'emplois les salaires sont plus élevés
les progrès sont énormes pour les
pauvres le niveau de vie des afro
américains n'ont jamais été plus élevé
les démocrates ont promis aux
afro-américains le monde et leur ont
donné l'assistanat
tron a promis de s'attaquer à leurs
problèmes et grâce à lui des milliers
d'entre eux sont sortis de la pauvreté
beaucoup d'entre eux ont des salaires
plus élevés que jamais le taux de
chômage est le plus bas il y a plus
emplois que jamais il bénéficie d'un bon
soutien des afro-américains maintenant
pour un président américain
même des rappeurs d'envergure le
soutiennent en fait pour le parti
démocrate est un parasite qui les
maintient dans ce système d'assistance
sociale et s'ils veulent en bénéficier
ils en sont dépendants
ceci découle en fait de leur système de
pensée socialiste agresseurs et bien les
chiffres pointé dans cette direction
pendant les dernières années du mandat
d'obama mais c'est un fait
toad individus sans assurance a grimpé
sous trump de 19% en 2016 à 13 7% en
l'espérance de vie qui certes était en
baisse déjà sous obama en 2014 a
continué de chuter
même chose pour les salaires selon
l'ethnie selon les données du troisième
trimestre 2010 9
le salaire hebdomadaire médian des
hommes noirs était égal à trois quart de
celui des hommes blancs alors je veux
dire oui mais c'est obama c'est est
égale à la moitié il a considérablement
augmenté sous trump voyez sur obama les
noirs américains ont énormément souffert
il n'a rien fait du tout pour eux depuis
trump ils ont les salaires et le taux
d'emploi le plus élevé et le taux de
chômage le plus faible
aussi le taux de mortalité a augmenté
sous obama alors que sous trump il a
baissé tous les ans y compris cette
année avec le nombre de victimes du coc
vite compris que c'est moins que dans
les quatre dernières années sous obama a
voulu tout les ans il est parvenu à
réduire le taux de mortalité y compris
cette année ce qui semble presque
impossible à faire 3 en plus quand vous
dites sans assurance ceux qui le sont
c'est parce qu'ils le veulent parce
qu'il préfère ne pas l'être et yang
pippo est long ce sont des jeunes ils ne
veulent pas payer
ils ont le sentiment qu'ils ne se
serviront jamais de leur assurance donc
ils ne veulent pas payer et il ne
voulait pas non plus payer les pénalités
imposées par obama c'est la raison pour
laquelle obama a perdu le combat et il
devait faire passer son obamacare et a
menti aux américains en disant qu'on
était autorisé à conserver son plan et
on ne pouvait pas en voulant lever à
conserver son médecin c'est totalement
faux
vous ne pouvez pas c'est le gouvernement
qui décide qui est votre docteur il qu'à
écouter vous les britanniques vous avez
une médecine mutualisé depuis très
longtemps il y a deux ans ma femme est
tombée malade à londres à l'école je ne
suis pas allé dans un de vos hôpitaux
vos citoyens m'ont dit de ne pas aller
dans votre hôpital
j'ai un médecin personnel et j'ai
beaucoup dépensé pour ça ico choses
changent car votre système de médecine
socialisée n'est pas un bon système
médicales pas plus que le système
canadien que la cour suprême du canada a
décrit ainsi pour nous la médecine c'est
vous inscrire sur une liste hockey est
d'accord c'est un sujet bien plus
profond nous ne dépensons que la moitié
de ce que dépensent les états unis je
vais simplement accélérer un peu comme
vous venez de parler
aucun américain ne passerai deux jours à
attendre dans un des hôpitaux et nos
politiques dans leur ensemble ne
seraient pas d'accord avec vous mais
j'aimerais parler de ce sujet des
américains de couleurs attendez une
seconde éloignons nous du système de
santé car je voudrais revenir
pourquoi pourquoi continuer encore avec
ce ridicule système socialiste
les votes américain de couleur pourrait
jouer un rôle décisif dans l'élection
pourquoi étant donné tous les progrès
qu'ont connu ces gens saouls trump est
d'ailleurs blacklight matters a débuté
suite à des violences policières encore
à l'époque de la présidence d'obama
alors pourquoi ce mouvement continue
t-il à critiquer l'administration trump
au lieu d'en faire les louanges alors
blake lively matters est une
organisation marxiste fondée par trois
femmes qui sont des marxistes jurés qui
ne cache pas qu'elle était formé comme
des marxistes leurs prédécesseurs ou
ancêtres étaient les black panthers
les black liberation army
il s'était donc entraînés par les black
panthers ou les black liberation army et
à toutes leurs manifestations qu'ils
appellent à tuer des officiers de la
police
liberty si vous parlez de l'expression
black live matters la vie des noirs
compte c'est une expression tout à fait
honorable mais si on parle de
l'organisation c'est une organisation
marxiste violente qui prône le meurtre
d'officiers de police ce qui a mené à la
mort de fichiers de police et à des
émeutes importante partout où en théorie
on devait manifester de manière
pacifique de semaine et ils causent
d'énormes dégâts à leur propre
communauté
ils ont détruit des entreprises gérées
par des noirs à travers tout le pays
il fera cassent les portes ils
débarquent ils pillent ce qui vient à
l'intérieur rien que la nuit dernière il
y a eu des pillages à philadelphie mais
en quatre jours de pillages
j'ai vu les images
un magasin a été éventrée il y avait des
gens venus de leurs banlieues qui
chargeaient leurs voitures de
téléviseurs sur ina et la police était
là en train de regarder tout ça parce
qu'à philadelphie
il y à un procureur mis en poste par
george soros aurait plus n'engage de
poursuites que dans une moitié de cas
qui préfèrent les criminels aux
innocents et le maire qui ne laisse pas
la police à arrêter les émeutiers hockey
georges soros tout comme la classe
matters ni rsa si george soros ne va pas
nier le fait qu'il est un donateur
majeur de blake lively matters george
soros ne peut pas nier le fait d'avoir
financé 27 élections de procureur de
district ou des procureurs complètement
incapable ont été élus des procureurs
qui n'engage pas de poursuites et laisse
les criminels partir libre gensse euro
c'est à lui seul responsable de
l'augmentation du taux de criminalité à
philadelphie il nie cela complètement le
fait est que nous parlions du système de
santé et nous savons également que ben
hayden et trump se prononcent tous les
deux ans en faveur du fracking trump a
dit qu'il réformerait le système de
santé
il n'y a rien eu de révolutionnaire dans
ses réformes jusqu'ici excepté cas
présent il évoque un prix de référence
des médicaments agaçant le lobby des
grands laboratoires big pharma lomé en
parallèle il dit qu'il va remplacer
l'accord de paris rien n'a vraiment été
concrétisé pendant ces trois ans et demi
dieu merci
l'accord de paris était une horreur il
permet à la chine de polluer la planète
pendant que nous restons assis à voir
nos économies prendre des coups car la
plupart des pays chez vous en europe
peut-être les piles de la chine mais pas
nous obama était dépendant machine est
maintenant nous savons pourquoi bayh
dole aussi car ils étaient payés pour ça
la grande bretagne souhaite visiblement
un accord post du bric site avec la
chine
vous êtes proche de ce pays vous
possédez un titre honorifique de
chevalier britannique que va-t-il se
passer si trump est réélu ou cib hayden
était lui en ce qui concerne ses
relations privilégiées étant donné que
la grande bretagne sort de lieu le jour
du nouvel an j'ai un immense respect
pour la grande bretagne
et je pense que le président aussi il a
clairement prouvé combien il se sent
proche des anglais et du gouvernement
britannique lorsqu'il s'y était rendu le
problème du président avec nos alliés en
europe c'est qu'ils ne paient pas leurs
factures un problème majeur c'est
l'allemagne
l'allemagne est un pays très riche il
paie moins de la moitié de ce qu'ils
sont censés payer pour l'otan aucun
accord commercial n'a été signé entre
les etats-unis et le royaume-uni même au
cours du dernier mois de sa présidence
et pensez vous que brydon signera
l'accord avec boris johnson beaucoup
plus rapidement dans ce contexte d'un
avenir post break site
seulement si quelqu'un le lit pour lui
je veux dire bayonne n'a presque plus sa
tête
vous devez le comprendre l'avez vous
déjà vu dire qu'il se présente contre
george john qu'il prête allégeance aux
états unis et tout le reste il le fait
qu'il ait confondu sa femme et sa soeur
le parti démocrate a des projets pour
dubaï donne c'est sûr il y a deux choses
importantes sur la base desquels ils
peuvent le shass et quand ils le
souhaiteront
ils peuvent convoquer dit psychiatre et
dire qu'il souffre de démence parce que
c'est vrai aussi
cech et deuxièmement maintenant qu'ils
ont ce disque dur qu'il était en train
d'utiliser pendant ces deux dernières
semaines
ils peuvent le prendre et ils peuvent
lui montrer toutes ses photos qu'il ne
veut pas que vous voyez paris mais il le
nie il y a encore d'autres crimes qui
ont été révélés vous m'avez posé une
question sur cette photo de hunter byden
vous savez vous savez pourquoi est-ce
pertinent parce que la chine possède
toutes ces photos et encore davantage
parce que c'est ce que fait la chine
pour extorquer les gens vous souvenez
quand les démocrates étaient tous
bouleversés que la russie puisse avoir
des photos de donald trump et de sa
famille et bien la russie a des photos
de baril donnent tout comme la chine
beaucoup de photos des milliers très
compromettantes et le parti démocrate
aussi s'étonne ne devrait pas
s'approcher de la maison blanche
il s'est trop compromis il nie qu'il
souffre de démence et pour les chinois
et les russes c'est impossible
fier c'est vrai c'est vrai il nie qu'il
souffre de démence mais encore une fois
il pense qu'il se présente contre de
georges il pense avoir travaillé au
sénat pendant 180 6 ans et qu'il confond
les noms des gens tout le temps avec et
il ne peut pas se souvenir des chiffres
et nancy pelosi a l'intention
d'assouplir les restrictions si un
président souffre d'une maladie mentale
ou de problèmes mentaux et on est qu'il
doit démissionner
il a dit que cela ne concernait pas
trump alors à quoi ça sert exactement
ne vous inquiétez pas je ne pense pas
qu'il sera élu et très brièvement pour
finir tout le monde en europe va être
vraiment surpris parce que les gens ne
font qu'écouter notre presse qui est
totalement biaisé et donc ils ont une
compréhension très réel de ce qui se
passe dans ce pays
peut-être que vous êtes au courant de ce
qui se passe à new york peut-être que
vous savez ce qui se passe à los angeles
mais vous n'avez pratiquement pas la
moindre idée de ce qui se passe dans
l'iowa alors très brièvement pour finir
concernant ces sondages
évidemment la dernière fois c'était à la
fin du jour du scrutin il y avait une
différence de deux points et bien sûr
trump a obtenu la majorité au collège
électoral
cette fois ci cela pourrait sans doute
être plus compliqué pensez vous que vous
allez soutenir officiellement la
compagne de trump si la situation est
similaire
hylas 1 % d' avance en caroline du nord
il a 3 % avance en floride
mais tout ce qui s'est passé ce week-end
c'est ce qu'on appelle un élan il y
aussi ce fait que trump à dole
enthousiasme byden n'en a pas et il ya
une raison qui échappe aux sondeurs ils
ne savent pas mesurer son enthousiasme
quand 25000 personnes sont là pour vous
ça veut dire qu'ils vont voter
lorsqu'une centaine de personnes sont là
pour vous elles vont voter mais il ya
une grande différence entre 25 me
laissant alors ce sera une grande
surprise et peut-être ils vont commencer
à regarder l'amérique plus attentivement
et ils vont arrêter d'utiliser le new
york times et le washington post
parce que tout ce qu'il reflète c'est
une élite très étroites pas la masse
américaine qui est constitué de bonnes
personnes qui font fonctionner ce pays
et qui le défendent une rudy giuliani
merci
[Musique]